this is a Fox News Alert the Orange
County Board in Orange County California
has voted to join the Trump
administration's lawsuit against
California and its sanctuary state law
Sandra Hutchins is sheriff of Orange
County and has fought that law by
publicly posting the release times of
illegal immigrant inmates California AG
Xavier Becerra told Fox News producer
Dan gallo
he may have sheriff Hutchins arrested
for that watch state law state law and
it's my job to enforce state law I I
will I will do so and we want to make
sure that every jurisdiction including
Orange County understand what state law
requires of the people and the
subdivisions of the state of California
[Music]
sheriff Hutchins joins us tonight
sheriff a lot of people on the East
Coasters waking up to what's going on in
California but it seems like we're
moving toward a crisis here is that the
way it seems to you know I it's not a
crisis it's we're as a as a sheriff of
Orange County I feel responsible for the
public safety of the citizens of our
County yes sb 54 does not allow for that
and so I have started yesterday posting
the names and dates of release of all
our inmates it's publicly accessible to
all of the community and that is well
within the law provided by SB 54 right
what I meant by crisis is you're the
chief law enforcement officer of your
County one of the biggest counties in
the state the chief law enforcement
officer of the state the Attorney
General is threatening to arrest you
that scene I've never heard of anything
like that happening in any state at
least in my yeah and I haven't either
and I find it interesting he may be he
better read SB 54 again because I don't
think he understands what the law says
and what I'm doing is entirely within
the confines of the law and I'm doing
what I think is important for my
constituents it's a public safety issue
to me it's not about immigration at all
it's about individuals who have
committed violent crimes
and let me just give you some examples
of some individuals we've had to release
how about sex with a minor child cruelty
domestic violence I mean I don't think I
could sleep at night knowing that I had
let somebody go and they go out and
commit another crime with those kinds of
charges so I am doing something well
within the law that helps me to notify
ice along with the community on when
individuals are being released it gives
ice an opportunity to pick up those
individuals who are in custody for
serious crime so we're not talking about
no I understand crimes we're not we're
talking about serious violent crimes no
you're acting out of obviously a moral
imperative that's non-political it's
it's it's your job description how would
the Attorney General arrest you and what
will happen if he tries well I wouldn't
advise it if he's going to arrest me
then he better have some good charges
because I'm gonna get an attorney and
and I'll fight it but I would be very
surprised if mr. Becerra decides to make
a move like that and arrest a sitting
sheriff for following the law just
because he doesn't like what I'm doing
that's not enough I'm following the law
and I'm trying to take care of my
constituents here in Orange County so I
wonder why other law enforcement
officials in other parts of the state
aren't doing what you're doing if what
you're doing is consistent with
California law I'm not sure I think some
are doing other things but I'm you know
I'm not going to speak to that but I
think there are some other jurisdictions
who are doing what they can to legally
under the confines of the law as it has
it's it's today doing what they can to
protect their their communities you know
the sheriffs in the state of California
fought this Senate bill from the very
very beginning and you know it's it
states that we cannot use any resources
to communicate with our federal law
enforcement partners knowing which is
just ludicrous well it's it's dangerous
as you pointed out sheriff thanks for
joining us appreciate it absolutely
thank you for having me